It started as an idea.
But here we are with actual actors.
A moderate special effects budget
and several low level X-Men.
None of the big ones, though.
We've got to save something for phase 2.
Welcome back everyone
Maximum effort
Marvel just announced that Deadpool 3
has been delayed
because of the recent strikes.
They've shuffled some of their
other Marvel movie dates as a result.
They also made some changes
to the story of Deadpool 3.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
There's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
We're in the middle of Loki season
2 episodes.
My episode 3 video will post next
but this morning as I'm posting
this video, you may have seen the news
Variety revealed that Marvel
has moved Deadpool 3 to October 2024.
It was originally coming out in May,
so we were supposed to get that first
Deadpool 3 trailer later this year,
it was not really what we had in mind,
though.
That didn't help things.
Marvel's Like Clockwork with big trailers
like that for their May releases
like Avengers, Infinity War,
Avengers Endgame, both May releases,
they dropped their trailers
around the same time
They were going to be promoting Deadpool 3
in a much bigger way.
one of the beauties of the Deadpool movies
is their marketing campaigns.
I feel like the first Deadpool
movie still has one of the top tier
marketing campaigns
of all movies Like that
and all the parody ads
they did for Captain America.
Civil War are still my favorite.
Like they have not top back,
even Avengers, Infinity War, Avengers
Endgame,
which they spent way more money marketing
Are you considering
buying this month's Empire?
You should because your favorite Merc
with the mouth hijacked
the entire editorial staff and made
the issue is very own.
That's right.
Empire's editors are locked in my crawl
space, desperately longing for the sweet
release of death that left me time to fill
these pages with whatever I wanted.
Deadpool 3 is going to be kind of
like a mini Avengers movie,
but for the classic Fox X-Men characters
who are coming back,
kind of like the Spider-Man
No Way Home for those characters,
like a test run
to see if people like the old characters
coming back,
if it works out, which it seems like it
well, it seems like it's going to do
gangbusters.
Kevin value will bring back more of them
during Avengers secret wars
and a few more years So generally
there's a lot riding on the movie,
a lot of expectations.
Just because people have been
so disappointed
with a lot of Marvel stuff
that has come out in the past
couple of years,
like the pandemic era of Marvel.
there's also rumors that Shawn Levy,
the director of Deadpool 3,
is going to wind up directing Avengers
Secret Wars just because he's
one of the very few directors in Hollywood
who's able to handle studio movies
that are that big.
Like it's a big thing to handle a studio
movie, like a big budget.
But doing an Avengers
movie is like ten times harder.
there'll be an army of characters.
They'll he'll have to juggle.
Most directors
don't want that kind of heat.
a lot of people
found out about this a while ago.
He has some funny comments
addressing all those rumors, making
it sound like it was actually kind
of true I read that rumor
and that's all I'm going to say.
His comments
there make it sound like he's
still negotiating with Marvel on contract
and what's going on with this story,
like how it's all going to play out.
but he's the person who literally just
Babe Ruth style called them
delaying Deadpool 3 just like a week
or two ago saying that the actors strike
which is still going on right now
threatened to delay the movie I somehow
thought this strike,
this second strike, would be averted.
And then suddenly it was upon us
and I had to send several hundred
people home and and they're still waiting
to come back to work.
So I'm just really I'm
I don't use this word lightly,
but I am yearning for a resolution
that feels
fair and equitable
and gets this industry back to work.
they just resolve the writer's strike
which would be going on
for most of this year.
But then the actors strike
kind of piled on top of that,
like they were both striking
at the same time.
Some of their issues were similar,
some of them were different.
currently most people that are like
actually involved with the strike that
no way more about it than me
believe that they're going
to resolve the strike by the time
Hollywood typically goes on Christmas
holiday break by the end of the year,
which is around the middle of November.
So it's not that far away.
But still, it could cause some more delays
for example, right now Ryan
Reynolds can actually change the script
because the writer's strike is over.
Like he can actually make
the script better, which is great,
but because the actors strike
is still going on,
he can't film any actual new scenes.
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine
can actually film any new scenes,
as a result, they moved it to October.
They've now moved Captain America
four Brave New World
into Deadpool's former spot.
That's coming out in May 2024.
I've really done a few videos
about Captain America four.
It's mostly about Anthony Mackie's
Captain America dealing with Thunderbolt,
Ross, who becomes
president of the United States.
He also becomes Red Hulk
finally play by Harrison Ford.
Now like this is Harrison
Ford as Thunderbolt Ross
They recast the character
because William Hurt passed away recently.
it's going to set up the new Avengers team
that we'll see in Avengers
5 Kang Dynasty.
They're setting up
a couple of other movies
like the Thunderbolts, some X-Men
related stuff to their Adamantium subplot,
it'll be kind of like Captain America
Civil War in that
that was a mini Avengers movie.
So Captain America
four will also be kind of like a mini
Avengers movie with a bunch of really big
characters in it.
They haven't fully revealed everyone,
but it sounds like a solid chunk of
the movie will also be setting up
their World War Hulk movie
that they're finally planning on doing.
No idea.
Will actually get to see that movie
like the Hulk solo movie.
But there were some reports
that Kevin Feige is finally in the process
of fixing their whole rights problem
with Universal
so they can finally release Hope
Solo movies again
it's like a really weird technical issue.
And it's mostly the lawyers on both sides
that are holding up Hulk movies
generally, everybody
has really amazing ideas for movies
and really amazing ideas for plots.
But usually it's lawyers
that get in the way of that stuff.
the only thing there's
not going to be changing in, like,
the next several years
is the whole Spider-Man rights with Sony.
Like, no way Sony ever lets those go.
They make way, way too much money
on Spider-Man movies in the spin off Venom
Birds movies,
even though it is more Ben time
makes it feel like a lot of them are duds.
They still make a lot of money
on all those movies.
getting to the big Deadpool 3
story changes
you may have heard about recently
with their whole X-Men plot.
Supposedly during the strikes earlier this
year, they changed the plot of the movie
and now the movie will not reference
anything from the eighth universe anymore.
Like they just removed
that entire part of the movie out
Previously the movie was going
to revisit the eighth at Universe
and see the aftermath of what happened
after Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness
in one Wanda's attack.
Mostly because that universe
was meant to be so comic book like it was
based on a much more comic book
accurate version of the universe,
where you have Fantastic Four,
X-Men, Inhumans, Avengers,
all co-existing on the same planet.
funny enough, that's kind of
what Kevin Fox is doing with this soft
reboot of Marvel and Avengers
Secret Wars is basically turning the MCU
into a more con book.
Accurate 616 Universe,
and he's been calling it the 616 universe
in the last couple of movies.
Now it sounds like they're finally going
to make it look more like the actual
comic book. 616 Universe.
most of Deadpool 3
is supposed to be the same, though.
Like the whole subplot explaining
how Wolverine winds up in
the movie is supposed to be similar.
The idea is that
Deadpool is jumping around the multiverse
looking for
the perfect version of Wolverine, but
he winds up learning that Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine is still the perfect version.
It's meant to be a big meta commentary
and joke on Kevin Feige
recasting all the X-Men characters,
like Kevin Feige is trying to get rid
of the old X-Men actors
by looking for brand new ones
who are perfect for the characters.
movie,
the movie's a little bit like Deadpool
kills the Fox Marvel Universe,
but he's also paying homage to the Fox
Marvel universe end, even though we clown
on a lot of those X-Men movies,
there are still a lot,
a lot of really solid movies in there.
Like X2 is still probably
one of the best X-Men movies of all time.
Days of Future Past
was still a really solid X-Men movie.
supposedly they're still doing the plot
with all the incursions destroying
way more universes way faster.
in. That's the whole Deadpool kills
the Marvel universe of it.
All the incursions are like
literally destroying
all these different universes
way, way faster.
in the TVA's
still a big part of the movie,
like Mobius is still in the movie
Miss Minutes.
The TVA characters are trying to save
as many characters as possible
by pulling them from these universes
that are being destroyed
and putting them on a version of MCU
Battle World with their pruning wands,
which might wind up being the void
because that's where everybody goes
when they get pruned,
setting them up for Avengers Secret Wars.
So like most of the characters
that you see in Deadpool 3
will not be in Avengers 5
Kang Dynasty.
They're actually
separating those two movies
by making them feel very different
and including
very different cast of characters.
So like Avengers 5
is more about like the new version
of The Avengers in the main universe,
fighting the Council of Kings.
And then when Secret Wars comes along,
it's more about these
multiverse characters
forming a multiverse, Avengers team
fighting whoever
the villain of that movie winds up being
with some of the characters from Avengers 5
Surviving into Secret Wars,
kind of like they did
with Infinity War in Endgame.
Like they were largely
felt like very different movies
with slightly
different cast of characters.
Like a lot of people
did not make it from Infinity War to end
until like
the very end of that final battle.
so it sounds like Deadpool 3
is going to end like right is secret
Wars is about to begin
and then they'll just say that Avengers 5
is taking place around the same time
as Secret Wars is about to begin,
and it'll be like the Infinity War snap,
kind of downer ending Empire Strikes Back,
kind of ending leading into secret wars
then Marvel using Secret Wars
is sort of like their soft
reboot point for the Marvel Universe,
making it eventually
look like a much more comic book.
Accurate 616 Universe.
So like all of the X-Men, Fantastic Four,
any other characters they want
will have coexisted on the same plane
the whole time.
Recasting
whichever characters they need to recast
and changing any back stories
to make sense that they need to
like Where the Fantastic
Four been this whole time?
Where are the X-Men been this whole time?
Like, it all just makes sense
when you head into Marvel Phase seven
beginning
like a much more core X-Men phase.
It sounds like they are going to pivot
a little bit
more to mutants during Marvel Phase
seven and beyond,
currently calling it the Mutant Saga,
but we'll probably get some more details
about that by the time we get to Avengers 5
Avengers six.
so even though some of the movies
are getting delayed,
they're only getting delayed a little bit.
And it's only a couple of the movies.
Like the only big delays are movies
that require actors.
Right now,
if they're just developing a movie
like they're just working on the script,
then it's not going to be delayed.
there's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
My Loki Season 2
Episode 3 video We'll post next.
Be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that.
Some really cool deleted scene
Easter eggs from previous movies.
They're bringing back in that too,
so I'll talk about that
during my full Loki episode 3 video.
Click here for that all I think the link
as soon as I post that and click here
to learn more about what's going on
with the big Marvel MCU reboot.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe and maximum effort!